ces volontaires préparent des colis
alimentaires à arques if la
contre-offensive ukrainienne a permis de
libérer des territoires il faut
maintenant aider celles et ceux qui s'y
trouvent
et nous sommes en train de mobiliser
toutes nos forces afin d'envoyer de
l'aide dans les territoires qui étaient
occupés tout est prêt on attend juste le
feu vert pour partir
des autorisations sécuritaire officielle
qui arrivent le matin suivant le long de
la route le convoi doit plusieurs fois
patienter face à l'hésitation de
certains soldats
arrivés sur place on comprend pourquoi
ça fait quatre jours qu'ils bombardent
tout le monde a peur il ya des roquettes
qui tombe des bombardements des tirs
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on doit juste
subir
les forces ukrainiennes ont repris
coupure en ce que le 10 septembre
pendant longtemps les gens ici ont été
privés des connexions téléphoniques et
d'accès aux médias on ne sait même pas
ce qui se passe à 100 mètres de chez
nous donc je peux vous dire que quand
leurs me craignent n est arrivé ça nous
a fait un choc
c'était une telle surprise n'en croient
en eux
pour certains la surprise a fait place
au soulagement
vous êtes des héros des héros nous
avaient attendu et je ne peux pas vous
dire combien je suis heureuse d'avoir
fait en sorte de vous apporter cette
aide est aussi ces drapeaux qui nous
réchauffe le coeur à la place des trois
couleurs russes partout
mais d'autres sont juste inquiet à cause
de la vague de violence que la
libération a provoqué
les forces armées ukrainiennes à couper
ans que sont encore en train d'essayer
de repousser l'armée russe plus loin de
l'autre côté de la rivière au skill qui
traverse cette ville ce qui fait que
coupet en ce que ne peut pas encore être
considéré comme une prise consolidé pour
l'ukraine contrairement à par exemple
idiome ou ballack les a plus à l'ouest